oh that's a big one it looks like a uh
just like a giant meteor just crashed
into someone's yard
so here's the thing
sinkholes are a phenomenon that freaked
me out how can the ground be sturdy one
second and then before you know it it's
sucking up buildings and cars and
children so what causes sinkholes and
can we predict them
there's a popular holiday spot in
queensland australia
where this has happened more than
[Music]
jason and wife mel nearly lost their
caravan that night
there was a lot going on that night
that's for sure and then you could just
keep hearing this funny stud
blood sound so it was a really humming
noise
sort of noise i didn't know what to
think it was the sound of sand
collapsing into the ocean just meters
from the campsite and it was of course
hard to see at night because it was dark
yeah no one knew what
what it was or what was going on they
knew it was just coming in closer and
faster and we just had to get out of
there but the amount it was dropping was
created
how quick it was going
for
partners and kids and wives and whatever
running around and screaming and crying
turned to manic and
people were just throwing things in like
we didn't even have time to fold our
beds up we just threw tables and chairs
on the
on the bed it was like a war zone down
there
we just managed to get it out in time so
we had to basically tell scream at
people to get out of the way literally
if we waited any longer i don't think
we'd have our car and caravan mate go to
that land freezer jason and mel were
lucky the campers next door lost their
caravan and car people you know
generators and gazebos and some chairs
and fire pits and so on all went missing
you know just yeah couldn't get too much
time and uh just gone down the hole yeah
it's memory that we'll never forget
headlines dub did a sinkhole but what
happened to in skip point was something
else entirely
now look it's often thought of as being
a sinkhole because it looks a bit like a
sinkhole like it's disappearing you know
if you're before your eyes in fact it's
just it's a slope instability there was
one crucial thing missing a hole a
sinkhole is normally um a near circular
feature and this is not this is like an
arc it's a bit like taking a spoon a
large spoon and taking a bit of a scoop
out of the coastline sitting at the
gateway to the largest sand island in
the world inscrip point is part of an
unstable sandy peninsula so what we see
at inscape these sub-vertical pillars of
sand
it's just a
precarious equilibrium normally we don't
find sand piled that way in a natural
condition two wet two stains decides
every now and then to give way
when it does give way it falls off in
vertical chunks
and it's held up temporarily by what we
call suction in the sand
and then all of a sudden that gets
swallowed it gets saturated and all of a
sudden you lose it again and forms
another almost vertical slope like a
sand castle
wet sand helps the shoreline stay
upright so it's just basically what
permits kids to build sand castles if
you watch it a little bit it gets almo
almost um some vertical but if you wet
it too much uh it gets washes out by the
water you know nature's a pretty
powerful force the ocean triggers this
rare phenomenon but what causes a true
sinkhole the sinkholes are different but
they're still related to water or water
flow basically there are cavities or
pets in the ground that form when water
erodes
or an underlying lock layer and then the
the ground above that
that
the developing sinkhole gives way it's
rare but there have been unexpected
cases in aussie backyards we get them in
urban developments we get them in uh
sometimes occasionally in the city in
the worst case not so much in australia
but in other parts of the world we've
had sinkholes that are big enough to
consume the house urban sinkholes are
usually the product of humans meddling
underground if we think about what's
happening nowadays digging
extraction mining activities increases
the intensity and frequency of the
collapse of simples so because of
anthropic activities we will expect this
to happen more frequently you could say
you know what proportion of the earth's
surface has has actually experienced a
sinkhole and that proportion would be
minute you know
so small you wouldn't even count it i
mean it's certainly not worth
people getting stressed about it
but oh we might have a sinkhole beneath
us we might all disappear
in a hole suddenly
i think that's going to be too far
you